Hey, this is absolutely nuts. I don't
want to spend a ton of time on this,
but I do want to mention it. You know
how the right wing loves to claim all
of the suppression of content happening
on social media and social networks.
It's right wing content that is suppressed.
It's left wing content that is propped up.
Every social network is trying to perpetuate
left wing ideas and suppress right wing ideas.
Well, you all know that we've had pretty
significant monetization problems with our
content on YouTube in the past. This story is
not about YouTube. The story is about Facebook,
we have been 100 percent demonetization Facebook
now I want to be really clear here. When I say
one hundred percent, I don't mean revenue is
down 80 percent on Facebook. OK, I don't mean
revenue is down 90 percent on Facebook. I don't
mean revenue is down 98 percent on Facebook.
Revenue is down one hundred percent on Facebook.
Facebook earned zero dollars and zero sense today,
zero dollars and zero since yesterday
and the day before. Why did this happen?
It happened because we covered
the story of Steve Bannon
suggesting Dr. Anthony Fauci should be
beheaded. Now, we didn't display any Gore.
We didn't advocate for violence. In fact,
we called out that this is a stochastic
terrorism event by Stephen Bannon. We
covered the story as it should be done.
And it got not that video demagnetized. Our
entire Facebook platform is deemed sanitized.
Now, as I've said over the years, the reason we
talk about membership support is this can happen
at any time. Two and a half years ago, three years
ago when YouTube apocalypse happened, we had no
warning. Just one day, boom. Ninety eight percent
of our revenue is gone. I texted Kyle Kolinsky. I
think it was a Sunday. Kyle, is anything weird
going on with your YouTube revenue? Kyle says,
yeah, my revenue is gone. Yeah, same here. Boom,
disaster. And it took a year for that to recover.
And over the years, as I've told you, my goal has
been we diversify revenue sources and that sort of
insulates us from when these things happen. And
case in point, because of YouTube apocalypse, we
diversified and have put a lot of time and energy
into Facebook, which has grown into a significant
revenue source for us. It's gone now. Hopefully
it's temporary. I don't know. We're going to try
to appeal this. We're going to try to fight it.
It's almost impossible. We have no contact at
Facebook. Facebook has some contact form where you
request an appeal. It's all automated. We've never
had an actual human from Facebook talk to us.
So this is why I say whatever shows you value,
it doesn't have to be this show. Understand
that the revenue on any of these platforms can
disappear overnight. It's disappeared overnight.
Support the shows you value directly. If you value
this show, I won't spend a lot of time on this.
Grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom. We have
this coupon code fresh start. All one word, all
lowercase, fresh start. We're taking a fresh start
with Joe Biden. I think it's self-explanatory.
It will discount any membership at join
Pakman Dotcom by 70 percent. I will let you know
what happens with Facebook. I will let you know if
nothing changes. But for the time being, we are
one hundred percent demagnetized. On Facebook,